[Music]
[Music]
all right people we are back I jokingly
said that we were gonna crash the
internet and I'm pretty sure we crashed
YouTube literally out of every live
stream we have ever done we have never
had an issue I don't know what happened
there I have conferred with these two
fine men and we're not willing to
completely go down the conspiracy theory
yet we're gonna have to just recap what
happened in ten minutes I believe well
first off Ben Shapiro to my left
ironically Jordan Peterson to my right I
believe that we are fully right now in
an idea revolution we talked about this
for about 10 minutes we'll try to recap
a little bit of what we started with and
then get to some more all new stuff as
I've said to the guys they're welcome to
talk directly to each other if they have
questions for me we can there are no
rules here there are never rules in here
but truly today there are no rules and I
think that these guys are in the thick
of something just tremendously important
right now and relevant and that's why
they're blowing up the way that they are
ok let's try to do some of that again
although you guys were both quite
eloquent the 10 minutes ago idea
revolution do you believe that we are in
an idea revolution right now well this
is what I think's happening I think and
I think this accounts for the
attractiveness of the content that I put
on YouTube so when Nietzsche diagnosed
the death of God about a hundred and
fifty years ago and his he made three
predictions he said people will as a
consequence our culture will shape - the
roots will become nihilistic or
totalitarian in response or will invent
our own values ok those were those were
his three possibilities and then and
then of course we became nihilistic and
totalitarianism totalitarian through the
20th century and many tens of millions
of people died as a consequence which
Nietzsche also foretold specifically he
said that a hundred million people would
die because of the rise of communist
ideas he said that in will to power so
then he predicted that while we would
have to invent our own values then the
psychoanalyst came along they said well
wait a second you can't you can't create
your own values because you're not
master in your own house there are
forces operating inside of you that are
autonomous and for Freud those were
proud
primarily biological forces but young
took that a step further and he said
wait a minute biology is a lot more
sophisticated and complex than you think
and there are symbolic forces at work he
thought of the archetypes as images of
the instincts for example but the
instincts were a lot more sophisticated
than people thought so it's not just an
instinct to aggression let's say there's
an instinct to operating properly so
that you walk up hierarchies human
hierarchies of competence it'd be
something like that and that's a that's
an archetype of the ideal in some sense
Jung thought the gods didn't disappear
they went inside they went into the
psyche and so he dove down as far as he
could dive to find out what those
eternal images were and to bring them
back up to the surface and that's what
I've been continuing I would say in my
lectures I'm saying look there's there
are elements to the ancient story that
are not only they're deeply correct and
you cannot live and you live in hell
unless you know them it's something like
that and that's the case so and I think
that's I'm hoping that's what is
happening is that people are starting to
understand that people people's lives do
have a transcendent purpose that's the
most appropriate way of looking at life
that our brains are in fact evolved to
reveal that purpose to us which I also
believe I think the neural neurological
evidence in that regard is quite clear I
believe that and so I hope I'm hoping
that what we're we're at the end of
postmodern despair that's what I'm
hoping yeah so to me what you're giving
there is sort of a realist version of
religion you're you're saying these
stories are needed for a very real way I
suspect you basically agree with that
yeah I mean I do and what's what's
fascinating about this is I mean Jordan
may be closer to Aristotle than I am to
Plato but I think that we almost have a
platonic versus a wrist is healing an
argument going on here because it seems
like what you're talking about is the
idea that if we dig down deep enough
into our biology's and into our neural
networks what we find is a common set of
shared values that if you refuse to
acknowledge them leads to grave
unhappiness and well I'm almost every
level right and what I'm coming from is
almost a platonic idea which is that the
mind of man reflects the mind of God the
extent that you can
not only is I would argue in Orthodox
your revelation is necessary but even if
you don't use revelation that using your
capacity to reason you can find a
purpose in something above but we end up
at the same place which is the set of
values that if you actually if you if
you stray away from this common set of
values and I'm talking like the most
root level values personal
responsibility freewill it's your job to
be responsible for members of your
family it's our job to make good
decisions and responsible decisions and
not to blame the society around you for
failures that you are yourself
responsible for you can't surpass your
own innate capacity and in in terms that
you can expect society to make up for
your lack of innate capacity in certain
areas you just have to make the most of
what you have in front of you you and I
agree on values but I think that the
source of the values there's gonna be a
slight disagreement I think I think it's
a it's a it's a profound place for
disagreement because and I don't
understand how to mediate it exactly
because I'm not willing to dispense with
the metaphysical no when I did my
biblical lectures last year I called him
up it's like a psychological approach
for a typical stories right because I
wanted to push a secular interpretation
a scientific interpretation which by the
way is not interrupted I think that
that's supremely useful to people
specifically because I mean despite the
fact that I come from a religious
background I'm trying to make arguments
that are not religious and orientation
and never cite to the Bible and I talk
about values for example I never cite
regulation it's valuable to me because I
think that that's a good source of the
values and I think that it's a relevant
source of the values but it is not the
only way to achieve those guys I've
never suggested for example that
atheists can't be moral or that you can
be an agnostic and not believe in
judeo-christian systems of Revelation
and come to the same exact set of values
that we're talking about now well and
it's also a simpler argument to make
because you constrain the number of
necessary very exactly so but that I'm
but having said that I'm not willing to
dispense with the metaphysical and I
think like I think it's and I'm like
stretching the edges of my cognitive
ability when I'm talking about this sort
of thing because I'm in realms that I
don't understand that it's it's that I'm
just getting vague pics ISM but I think
it's as if there's a there's a
revelation from evolution that matches
the revelation from above the new things
come together and I
I don't understand how that can be
possible I think it has something to do
with the fundamental nature of
consciousness which is something we
seriously do not understand and so I can
see you can make a straight biological
case for the evolution of archetypes but
I don't think that the biological
explanation exhausts the archetype
there's more to it and because and what
I've learned too in delving into these
religious stories but also into
religious experience is that it's
bottomless like there is a point where
as you dig into the archetypal
everything turns into one thing
biological spiritual transcendent it's
all one thing from the top to the bottom
and I think people get intimations of
that when they have profound experiences
experiences that are generated by music
for example it might love for my sex or
there's a variety of ways that they can
be anytime you have an experience of
meaning in your life and I can also see
that and I believe this to be the case
is that you are you're neurologically
adapted to a universe where meaning is
the highest instinct and I mean that
technically is that when you're sitting
in a situation where what's happening
around you is meaningful what your
nervous system is signaling to you is
that you occupy the optimal position in
the dynamic territory that you currently
inhabit and that's and that sense of
meaning is it's not just cortical it's
it's way deeper than merely cortical and
so that's a very exciting that's a very
exciting discovery I would say I think
that because the again a place where we
agree is that meaning is uncovered it's
not some it's discovered it's not
something that you're making up yourself
and that's why I think it's revealed
exactly and because we're going
happiness exactly and I think that one
of the reasons that that the message
that we're putting out there is is
making people happier actually mmm even
though we're both pessimists by nature I
would think is that what we're basically
saying is that in this land of chaos
where you could have wandering around
with no meaning there is a meaning and
if you search for it you'll find it but
you haven't be open to the concept that
there is a meaning yes we discover yes
and if you shut yourself out from that
by just saying there's no meaning to be
discovered meaning is to be made up by
you and you can do what you want a
phenomenal right exactly
it's just something that you experience
but it's not really real
you know that that kind of stuff is is I
think disquieting to people and so
there's something that quiets the soul
yeah that says you have purpose and and
if you don't have purpose then maybe
it's because you're searching in the
wrong place yeah whatever
yes possibility that's right there's a
few interesting things that you said
there because it's like I know you guys
pretty well at this point and and this
crew of people that were sort of in when
when we're off camera we're actually
talking about the exact same thing it's
like we are lit whether this camera was
on right now or off like we're living
this thing all the time I think it's I
can speak from my own experience in this
regard it's made me a better person and
I will and I'm still striving to be
about I'm more authentic I'm more honest
I'm constantly I mean I sit in this
chair when it's over there and look at
the person over here every week and I
actually hear and I listen right and I
sit across great minds and I go wow I
have to reevaluate some of the things
that I think and I sometimes it's
because I disagree with someone you know
and I'm like they really don't know what
they're talking about but often it's
hopefully that I'm hearing somebody say
some great right this is what's really
interesting and I think what's what's
great about conversations like this one
is when yeah if I have Jordan on my
facebook live and I ask him questions or
he'll have me on his YouTube and he's
asking questions what we're all really
in the business of all of us who are
occupying the spaces asking questions
and we're treated as weird because we're
asking the questions if they're actually
listening to the answers yeah exactly
I always think well you know you might
have something to tell me that's my rule
number eleven by the way yeah right
assume that the person you're listening
to might know something you don't
right I mean because then you can they
can tell you that to you and if you
learn it then you don't have to run face
first into a brick wall
exactly it's really helped and and from
Jewish tradition that's deeply embedded
in Jewish tradition that the wise man is
the man who learns from every man around
him hmm and so this idea is is it's what
unifies this really disparate stream of
people yeah the three of us people like
sam harris people echo rogen right I
mean like you look at me and Joe Rogan
what we have we like asking questions
right we actually look like you and
there's different species well that's
how I found the same thing when I was on
Chaco willings podcast it's like you
know we're we're very different people
but that's what's in common is that
we're able to have a conversation we're
actually able to have a conversation and
and that we're aiming I think we're all
aiming at making things better rather
than worse which is also a very
important thank Tomas
one of the things that makes that happen
is the fact that we are as you say
talking about first principles all the
time when people will talk at the top of
the iceberg then it's impossible to for
them to even see sometimes that they're
actually standing on two different
icebergs right they're not seeing the
commonalities of and they're not seeing
what's different like if I argue first
principles with somebody then you can
see how those first principles manifest
in political differences in the business
that I'm in but if you're just arguing
about a certain political policy without
examining anything that goes underneath
there then you just end up clubbing each
other and not even understanding what
the other person saying cuz you don't
understand the set of values they're
deriving those political polls part of
the problem that we have right now in
our culture is trying to diagnose the
level at which the discussion should be
taking place and I think the reason that
this is a tumultuous time is because it
actually is a time for discussion of
first principles and it's it's that
first principles are virtually at the
level of theology because first
principles are the things that you
assume and then move forwards like well
what should we assume well the dignity
of the human soul let's start with that
you can't treat yourself properly
without assuming that you can't have a
relationship with another person you
can't stabilize your family you can't
have a functional Society so what does
it mean for this human soul to have
dignity well the part of the idea is
that you're participating in creation
itself and you do that with your actions
in your language and you get to decide
whether you're tilting the world a bit
more towards heaven or a bit more
towards hell and that's actually what
you're doing so that's a place where the
literal and the metaphorical truth comes
together and people are very they're
terrified of that idea as they should be
because it's a massive responsibility
it's a massive realization of
responsibility to understand that all
the decisions that you make during the
day are decisions between hell and
heaven essentially and but I think there
is no truer way of saying that so as you
guys have both sort of hit the level
that you're at and I was at the turning
point thing with you couple weeks ago
and you literally came out it was like
the Rolling Stones came out I mean
people people were going bananas I
talked about all my political
differences with them that we've
discussed about being pro-choice and for
gay marriage although they're basically
okay with that and and being pro pot and
all that and I got a standing ovation we
did our thing in
sin and the line for you after was
longer than the line for me and I told
you this but I was like man that makes
me want to be better I have to I wasn't
jealous of you I was like man he's doing
something great and I have to be better
so my question for you is this was all
meant to be right I mean without going
to religious or metaphysical but the
internet sort has now allowed all of the
people that were watching television and
seeing pop culture and gone something is
really wrong here something is missing
the Internet has sort of forced us
together I mean that's this this growing
group is because we're it's not because
we're all looking for it it's because
we're being forced together and what's
really funny is the way that everybody
is introduced to our work is is the same
way but it's the way that you wouldn't
expect so most people I think Jordan
originally saw you in a confrontation
with somebody over transgender pronouns
right and that's how most people began
to engage and then suddenly you are
getting 500,000 views on discussions of
biblical stories from Genesis which I
mean let's be frank if if the first
thing never happens 5,000 because right
and the same thing is true for me right
the way that I originally kind of drew
public attention was because I was on
Piers Morgan's show and I shall act him
on a show and so all of a sudden people
were now listening to our long lectures
about about you know my ideas on
philosophy and root principles of the
founding fathers if it came for the
scandal and stayed for the content and
that's and that's I think the advantage
that it takes a particular skill set for
everyone in this space to be able to do
that but that's that's the beauty of the
of the YouTube moment and of the
Internet moment is that people are
engaging it in the news level if you
just watch any new cable news channel
the news cycle is about 30 seconds long
then there's the headlines again and so
that's the level at which we consume but
if you see every sees the flashpoint for
you or the flashpoint for me or the
flashpoint for Sam with Ben Affleck or
the flashpoint for you with number many
of them for you and then they and then
they want more and it's the introduction
of it it's basically the gateway drug
like there's a 30-second video that's
the gateway drug to these two hour-long
lectures about deeper principles and
people and the reason that the question
is why those flash points flash and I
think that because what makes those
different what makes it that people want
to see that and then they go okay now I
want to see the rest of their content
and start streaming tons of videos from
these folks happy newman video so is a
good
yeah so let's get to that one second I
just want to leave that is is just that
I think it's incongruity they see
something different and if you notice
difference in the society on any level
then you are automatically a pariah and
an outlier and we all know deep down
that there are distinctions and
differences to be made logically between
I'm not talking about groups of people
ethnically you know for some odd reason
I'm talking about just logical
distinctions between modes of thought
and logical distinctions between between
certain policies and if you are willing
to draw distinctions instead of just
saying that we have to exist in this
morass of identity politics that's it's
a flash in the darkness and people
gravitate toward the light like mom well
it's partly because the problem with the
problem with relativism let's say let's
say that that did produce a radical
state of equality well the problem with
that is that there's no up and the
problem with there being no up is
there's no hope and the problem with
that is that people actually live on
hope yes so if you flatten out the value
structure so that there's no qualitative
differentiation between things then
there's nothing to do so that's just not
helpful and so then you can tell people
look make no mistake about it there is
down that's hell that's our switch
that's the gulags like that's down that
exists that exists in your own family
you can create that with no problem and
because there's a down like that there's
also an up and that up is worth aiming
at even though it differentiates people
as they climb towards it it's still
without that you you can't have the
purpose in your life that gives it
meaning and nobility in the face of
suffering well they don't know that
that's interesting because that's why I
sort of think it's almost like we're all
Frankenstein's monster in a weird way if
the if the mainstream media had been
dealing honestly with the issues of the
day whatever they are identity politics
or post-modernism or just the general
political discussion then I don't think
people would react to you guys the way
that they do because they they didn't do
their job but really quickly because yet
as you hit these so you're more I think
there were three moments and you already
hit them but just for people that that
aren't following all this you on Piers
Morgan basically bashing him endlessly
with facts over feelings about guns was
one where it was like this guy from the
internet just beat this CNN person how
did that happen and
I think you know the one that changed me
more than anything else everyone knows
this already was sam harris on real time
with with affleck and they got into this
stuff about about the difference between
Muslims and Islam I didn't even know who
Sam was I see this mild-mannered
neuroscientists and a nice suit calmly
talking about Pew Statistics next thing
you know he's gross and racist but but
this is a good segue to yours because I
think yours is the third one and the way
that it this is just two or three weeks
ago you were on with Kathy Newman on
it's Canada channel for most UK channel
four and there's I mean everyone that's
watching this has probably seen this
already if you haven't go watch it but
but in effect basically she tried to
make an argument that you have heard a
good jillion times before but why does
your right to free speech supersede a
trans person's right to feel okay with
themselves or saying they even the way
she phrased the question was a little
confused and conflated but the thing
with the reaction to it what you know
your answer was great but it was the
reaction to regular people watching at
home then we're gone this is nonsense
this is just object no well the only
thing that really made it viral is the
fact that she recognized it in the
moment don't you say where you could see
the light go on briefly and she just
went wait what did I just say yeah and
there was no escape it was pretty it was
pretty grand yeah yeah well the funny
thing about her argument is that it's
print was predicated on the idea that
somehow people have a right to be
comfortable it's like that's just not a
right you have in life of all the things
you can say that you don't have a right
to in life being comfortable is number
one it's what you made that point yeah
who can offend me right now so the thing
is is if you if your right to be
comfortable Trump's my right to talk
then I don't get to talk ever because
I'm going to say things if I'm actually
talking I'm going to say things if
they're if they're profound things if
they're contentious things or truthful
things I'm going to say things that if
they don't disturb you are gonna disturb
you and if they don't disturb you
there's someone that's gonna be
disturbed about them so what's the
answer to that everyone can be
comfortable in the silence but that
doesn't also doesn't work because then
we can't exchange ideas we're not
comfortable in the silence we're
isolated and and in the silence so it's
a completely incoherent perspective but
what does that tell you about just the
way
mainstream media operates because if you
even even just in this last week when
I've read some of the pieces about you
that I think are so dishonestly
attacking the way you do things or even
you know I'll see sad there was an
article about you and it was like Ben
Shapiro is the cool kids philosopher or
something yeah and it was like well wait
a minute when did the cool kid be the
smart Orthodox Jew you know too late
how did then you've talked you talked
about the [ __ ] that you went through
when you were growing up and all that's
nothing and you don't want to play like
this no regularly I can't imagine yeah
small and noisy exactly and I could have
taken care of both you I always say I
was right on the middle of sort of like
loser and cool so like I actually did
believe the kids below me but I was
bullied by the guys there I was right
there may be keep the world in balance
there you go
but but this idea that when they write
the article it's the cool controller
even though obviously you didn't grow up
as the cool kid or James d'amour it's a
great one where they write articles
about him and they'll say the the tech
bro and it's like if you you both have
met James d'amour but he's the shyest
quietest DC does really you almost
literally have to drag sentences oh yeah
what a spine of Steel no you know it's
really something yeah
fearless yep despite what his
disposition may actually be but but what
do you make of that the way that they
try to frame it so they're already
trying to undercut you know I mean
before it before you even use it not to
use your model but I think that they're
trying to impose their own order on the
chaos it's just the wrong frame so
that's what happened in the Channel four
interview and it's it's sort of I was
thinking about the model that you were
describing with regards to your position
on the iceberg is that Kathy had staked
out a position on the iceberg and I had
staked one out that was way lower like
way lower and what happened was she kept
questioning me at her level of analysis
and that just wasn't working because
that wasn't the level of analysis at
which I'm playing and and well and I'm
also not playing although I'm trying to
play yeah I know what I mean a little
bit but yeah like wrestling you had a
lower base of gravity mm-hmm
I think that that gave you an advantage
and that's well part of me I wasn't
trying to win the interview right you
know like I and I don't try to win
interviews I try to go to an interview
and have a talk and have a discussion
and see how it goes and I don't have an
agenda except to not make a catastrophic
mistake that's agenda number yeah don't
say anything
unforgivably stupid yeah but I think
that's it I think that's the other thing
that makes all of this unique is that if
you actually meet any I mean we've all
met each other in the circle now because
it's really funny how life works that
way that these circles are so small
though we know each other and we
actually talk with each other and all
this that's what I think they're voicing
us together it's not even that we're
seeking each other but it's also that we
all have a certain a certain baseline
personality that we all have and that is
we enjoy the discussion we actually
enjoy the exchange of ideas and so when
you're on with Kathy Newman she says
stuff that like what you were getting
from the right wing a lot was how do you
even stand this how do you in stand this
interview right how can you get through
a half an hour of this and you've done
it and I've done it too and the answer
is because I sort of enjoy it I mean
this is what we do for a living right
yeah the idea that that I don't enjoy
having conversations even with people
who don't get it it's not enjoyable with
having your views radically
mischaracterized as Kathy Newman was
trying to do to you that's irritating
right that was so over the top that it
was hardly even irritated thinking well
I don't know who you're talking to but
it isn't me right exactly exactly and so
because of because of that that's the
most infuriating thing to people on on
the hardcore left and in the media
because if they can't fit you into that
frame it's what you were saying before
the show started if they can't fit you
into this preconceived in a Russian
nesting doll that know that they've got
for you if you don't fit in there then
they can't do anything with you and if
you're an open-minded person who
actually likes to hear exchange of ideas
and you're willing to admit that there's
a piece of evidence you may not have
considered yet it's almost impossible to
be caught off guard hmm right and but
these people refuse to acknowledge that
there's evidence they haven't considered
yet or they just throw away the evidence
like if I brought you a piece of
evidence that contradicted your
worldview say okay that either fits in
my worldview or it doesn't if it doesn't
but it's a real piece of evidence here's
how I have to kind of shape and change
my worldview in order to accommodate
that piece of evidence and I think
that's what smart and decent people do
but it's not a Knowles I think that's
why Joe show is so graceful is because
you know he's not a
classical intellectual he talks about
ideas a lot but the thing about Jo is
he's actually curious he when he asks a
question he'd like to know the answer
you know and it's not so that he can
demonstrate that he's right like he has
his viewpoints obviously like everyone
does because you have to have a
viewpoint but he does ask the questions
he'd like to know the answers to and
that's that and YouTube seems to reward
that so hooray for that when it's also
the fact that it's a longer forum a
longer spam forum is also a non-trivial
advantage because people can take the
time to read igg into something I don't
think a lot about what makes all of
these various people of such different
stripes successful and what I realized
is that so much of it is just like in
any movie the reason they watch a movie
is because you know where the movies
gonna end it's gonna end with the movie
turning off the screen and then you're
gonna leave the theater right every
movie ends the same way
but it's you're there for the journey
and so when you watch your show did and
you're actually trying to pursue things
and take people along your thought
journey and when you watch your lectures
on the Bible and you're tracking them
along a journey a journey of exploration
and certainly with Joe's show or Joe is
taking you for three hours through his
thought process asking questions and
going somewhere and even when I'm doing
my political show my idea is here I'm
gonna lay out all the evidence and I'm
gonna try and piece it together so that
we get to a conclusion together and you
can disagree with any step I take along
that way but here's the journey we're
gonna go along so you can follow along
with me I think what the media do is
they just go straight from the beginning
of the movie to the end of the movie
with no journey they just go okay here's
the intro right Luke Skywalker is is on
a planet by himself and then you just go
straight to the Millenium Falcon flying
wait wait just what happened in the
middle there well I think it was that
why we're then or let's say you're at
your moment with Kathy that we're sort
of the glitch in the system now like to
me that was the young decidable Zin in
postmodern terms there you go right
that's it that worked that that's a
glitch like if we were watching the
matrix that's the glitch that you got to
the to the wasn't on YouTube this was on
we you know real television not that
that even matters more than this cuz I
think this is the real thing now but you
caused the glitch that's what you did
you caused the glitch in her she
actually couldn't come up with words
after but you actually it was actually a
glitch in the system that then yeah well
that was aided everything else that
you're do is an imposed narrative and I
mean part of that's a consequence of the
pathology of the medium I would say is
that one of the things that's really
stop watching televised news like 25
years ago but one of the things that
made me stop was my realization that the
newscasters would show a politician
right and then they'd give him like his
ten seconds or heard her ten seconds to
say something then they fade out the
audio then the newscaster would tell you
what the person said and what it meant
and I thought oh that's not so good
that's that's there's something gone
gone horribly wrong there and I think
that's it's become more and more like
that over the last thirty years partly I
think that's because journalism itself
classic journalism is degenerating you
know it's becoming a more and more
desperate game for for smaller and
smaller stakes but YouTube offers
something that the that the traditional
broadcasters just can't offer and that's
weirdly enough for something that
started out with cute cat videos it's
actual depth and the capacity to have
like a three-hour conversation turns out
people actually like that but that's why
I think that you two are particularly
interesting cases because I view you as
sort of like a pure political beast and
yet you've because of all of this you
now talk about religion I think more
than probably you inherently want to
perhaps or all of these other things and
you as a clinical psychologist this is
but that's where you really started and
now you end up talking about politics
all the time so again this is why we all
sort of got forced into this I think
that in the end we end up in the same
frameworks at the ancient Greeks ended
up in right they would all write a book
on ethics and they'd write one on
politics and then who'd write one on the
polity and it all comes together I mean
if there is no such thing as a political
but by the same token there's no such
thing as a epical right I mean if you're
if you well if you are operating in the
sphere of politics you are going to end
up if you dig deep enough in the same
waters that Jordan is used to being and
if Jordan elevates you know up on that
chain far enough he's gonna end up in
the sphere where I'm used to operating
which is why their videos are you
talking to transgender people about
about pronoun use so you know there's
what happened to me I think was that
like I was operating in a let's call it
a psychological level or level of
archetypal story essentially and then
the political intervened in that and
said I'm going to interfere with your
freedom of speech it's like no that's
not happening I know where that goes
well and then of course one of the
scandals that emerged out of that this
year was the scandal of Lindsay Shepard
at Wilfrid Laurier University which was
the biggest scandal that ever hit a
Canadian university and it was like had
I in my most pessimistic
prognostications about the consequences
of Bill c16
I didn't envision the Inquisition of
Lindsay Shepard so thank you very much
postmodernists for making that manifest
so clearly scientist in the room so if
you can you tell that story oh yeah well
there was a teaching assistant a great
episode on the Rubin report okay quite
the creature she's a they picked what
they messed with the wrong girl we
happened after her but she was in the
communications department at Wilfrid
Laurier University in Canada and she had
the temerity to show a five-minute clip
of me just debating the biological
reality of gender let's say with a
professor Nicholas mat who famously
claimed that there were no biological
differences between men and women and
that was the scientific consensus for
the last four decades she showed a
five-minute clip to her class well and
hypothetically someone complained
although it turned out that no one
really did yeah and that was brought to
the attention of her professors and to
an administrator named Adrian Jewell who
was basically hired as a you know as an
inquisition as I would say by the
university under legislative pressure
and they raped her over the coals for an
hour and she taped it and she made it
public and it's it was a tape in which
they compared they said that playing a
video of me debating pronouns was
neutrally because she said she did it
neutrally and there's no reason to
disbelieve her was tantamount to playing
a video by Hitler neutrally or while you
Napoles the radical leftists are so
clueless that they can't even get their
insults right so I'm not my low you know
Alice or Hitler it's it's you know
stories what are the other diamond in
this photo if you think this boat has
some people at it yeah boat I mean even
right now we know that you know
someone's gonna write about this and
write that this was the gathering of the
all right and all that other nonsense
but in a weird way do we owe the Potter
postmodernist some thanks then because
if you think about it they took they
forced someone like Lindsay to be public
now and I and I think she's wonderful
and has you know just incremental and
getting shallow red wine
right like all these all of these people
you guys me I mean everyone out of the
James d'amour I mean he only is someone
now with influence because they forced
him to address these issues so in an odd
way we owe them I mean for all the
complaining that we might do about these
people we owe them because they've
sharpened not only they've not only
sharpened us intellectually but I think
they've allowed these other people to
wake up well the post modernists had a
point like the point is is that the
world is susceptible to a near infinite
number of interpretations that happens
to be true
that's why developing artificial
intelligence especially perceptual
systems has turned out to be so
difficult it's very very difficult to
perceive the world because you can
categorize it in literally a near
infinite number of ways okay and then
the next claim was well it's very
difficult to rank order those ways in
terms of quality like yeah that is very
difficult but then they pushed it too
far
therefore there are no qualitative
distinctions between modes of
interpretation its interpretation all
the way down it's like no no good good
point hard to disagree with but
fundamentally wrong there's a finite set
of viable interpretations it's really
the layman's the layman's term for that
would be that some things are real right
I mean is that the simplest way to say
it there are some things that actually
are real I think that's that's that's
one objection another objection is there
are some modes of being that lead you to
Perdition yeah very very rapidly and
that's and that isn't somewhere being
human that you actually want to go so
there's the material reality that's
outside the interpretive framework you
know but then there's an ethical reality
that that isn't material in the same
simple sense but there's an ethical
reality that's also not merely a matter
of interpretation I mean the best
example of that I know is Jack panksepp
sock panksepp to work with rats I mean
there's lots of models of this in the
animal kingdom but that this one's
particularly good so juvenile rats like
to wrestle so if you pair two rats
together to males because they
particularly like to wrestle and one of
them is ten percent bigger than the
other the big one with the ten percent
weight advantage can pin the little one
consistently okay so you say you pair
them once they'll work to do this
because they enjoy it
the big one pins he wins now he's the
dominant rat you think well there's
dominance among rats yeah except that
isn't how it works because rats in the
wild live in social groups and they'll
play with each other continually across
many games so then let's say you pair
the two rats together constantly okay
after the first bout the little rat the
loser has to invite the big R out to
play that's the rule so he does his
little play maneuvers and the big rat
thinks yeah yeah okay I'll play if you
pair them repeatedly unless the big rat
lets the little rat win 30 percent of
the time the little rat will stop
playing with them I read that and just
blew me away I thought wow look at that
in rats which have been used as a model
for human behavior for psychologists for
like a hundred years in rats there's an
emergent ethic of fair play that emerges
across iterated games it's like really
yeah it's mind boggling so we could use
that that would be an example of like
when I'm playing basketball with my
eight-year-old nephew I occasionally let
him win yeah because I want to because
he needs that reward yeah I'm going if I
just beat him mercilessly and if you're
good you let him win when he does
something particularly spectacular him
there's this thing called the zone of
proximal development and it turns out
that adults speak to children naturally
at a level that's slightly above their
level of comprehension so that's the
meaning zone essentially and so you keep
the kid there because the kid can talk
but also learn at the same time and if
you're really playing well with your
eight-year-old nephew you're gonna let
him win when he's pushing himself a
little harder than you normally would
you think well that's he is winning when
he's doing that and so you want to set
up the game to reward him and that's an
ethic that transcends mere
interpretation it's not it doesn't only
apply to human beings it applies and
Fran's de Waal who studied chimpanzees
he's found quite clearly that it isn't
the most tyrannical chimp who stays on
top because the chimp tyrant who has no
friends who does no mutual grooming
who's not reciprocal it's like he has an
off day and two of his enemies tear him
to pieces
so the tyrant chimp sits atop a very
unstable hierarchy and so I've thought -
in the West we don't have dominance
hierarchies
we have competence hierarchies and those
completely different and you have to be
a good player of iterated games to
maintain your position in a competence
hierarchy and that's the beginnings of a
discussion about something like a
fundamental ethic so that's interesting
I think I can segue this to a little bit
of the way that some of the media deals
with you is that you because you are
fact-based you talk fast you you don't
care I mean you genuinely don't care
about people's feelings III know you
pretty well now you don't that they met
immediate family maybe your wife but
that they don't know how to respond to
that then because they're used to
dealing in a realm that is all about
that so now you come out and you're like
no no no this is the way it is I'll
debate you but you're not gonna beat me
just because you happen to be gay or a
woman or whatever else it is and I think
actually now that's a lot of the reason
of your your surge well I think that
most people at root level don't actually
want to think of themselves as their
group identity first I think most people
want to be respected on an individual
level and so when I say in order for you
to be respected on an individual level
that means that I'm not going to respect
you on the group level right meaning I'm
not that your group identity doesn't
mean anything to me your individual
identity means everything to me but your
group identity means nothing to me
and when I say individual identity I
don't mean how you identify you know in
terms of race or gender I mean in terms
of your thoughts are your thoughts
interesting or are they right or are
they wrong and they're either right or
the wrong and they're interesting or
they're not and that doesn't change
based on who's saying it and if we could
all get there I think that that's what
people find appealing is that if you can
get there then you can actually have a
discussion about ideas if not then
you're just gonna retreat into your
identity and there's no way for me to
have a discussion with you I mean I just
had a talk at UConn and one of the
students got up and was talking about
abortion then she said you know I I
would never have an abortion but you as
a white privileged male how could you
talk about abortion and I said because
right is right and wrong is wrong
regardless of whether I am a white
privileged male I mean that's the basis
for Western civilization otherwise I
can't have it we can't have it's right
and then what happens if we can't have a
conversation across group can we just
fight for dominance that's that's
exactly well that and that's the
postmodern worldview yeah that that's
all we're doing it's like fine but like
you're you're you're opening the door to
the radical right-wingers because there
to come in and say okay no problem we'll
play identity politics but I'm not
losing how's that right like well that
isn't the way you're supposed to play
you're supposed to be guilty it's like
no sorry I'm not gonna be I'm just gonna
be dominant exactly this is the danger
of the the actual wall right because
what the on rate is it's a reactionary
identity politics movement and the left
doesn't want to acknowledge its own role
in helping to drive the the emergence of
a reaction or identity politics movie
which by the way I find despicable
because I think all identity politics
movements yeah artists exactly what I
think to that I don't kami and I traitor
left I did a year of shows on if the
left doesn't clean them and when I was
still saying I'm on the left if we don't
clean up our house what is going to
happen and look what has happened so
shifting slightly a little bit I thought
this would be interesting is there a
criticism actually I'll start with you
for his in this one is there a criticism
of you that you think is the most legit
no criticism of me you know I I think
that the the criticism of me that I
think is legit is one that I think is
probably common in most people which is
I tend to fall into confirmation bias
which is true for everybody so you know
I think that but it you know when you're
in the political realm the easiest thing
to do is to find evidence that supports
your position and cherry-pick the
evidence in order to support that
position and so if the idea is that I
tend to do that I try to fight that but
I'll acknowledge that that's a flaw that
I have that that you know when you're
when you're invested in a political
fight that the easy that that your
easiest mode of confrontation is to find
stuff that supports what you already
think as opposed to taking in all of the
available evidence and then shifting
every point as we were talking about
before toward the toward the right
position it's because I think it is a
weakness it's something that I that I
try to fight as often as possible and I
tried to make provision for that so
before I ask you yours what what do you
what do you think what do you think is
wrong with then and B what do you think
is psychologically the best way to deal
with that to be to be aware right you're
being aware of what your issues
limitations are what your biases might
be psychologically what around yourself
with competent people who who have their
areas of expertise that aren't yours and
to listen to them you know and that's
that's helped me over the last
18 months cuz I've had about ten people
around me five of them are family
members about five of them were friends
who are extraordinarily competent people
and they go over what I've been doing
and they're they don't pull any punches
this feelings thing this is something
I'd like to spring to your defense about
because the rule if you don't have an
ethicist don't hurt anyone's feelings
it's like okay but which feelings do you
mean what do you mean like this seconds
feelings or do you mean the person's
well-being across a year because lots of
times when you're having a firm
discussion with someone that upsets them
in the present this happens with
children all the time is your you're not
taking stock of their feelings at the
moment except insofar as you have to
because you want to help prevent them
from cascading into catastrophe for the
rest of their life right well I'm gonna
discipline you right now I'm gonna tell
you why you were wrong we're gonna have
a hard conversation because if you keep
that up your life is going to be a
never-ending stream of misery well
that's not cruel and so but because
people don't see the ethic of iterated
games let's say something like that they
say well you just shouldn't hurt
anybody's feelings in the moment it's
like no well this is this is why I think
both you and I object to the whole idea
of the pleasure pain matrix being the
thing that matters in terms of human
happiness right because the bottom line
is that you may be experiencing a good
deal of pain right now but that's going
to lead to a more fulfilling life
that's the utility of sacrifice right
everyone knows that give up something
now in a rather painful way and you may
benefit in the future yeah pain the pain
pleasures ethic doesn't work because of
the problem of time and time and other
people that's another reason that
doesn't work so it's you need a way more
sophisticated solution to that so so now
let's turn that question to you what do
you think is the most legit criticism
that you see because I see a lot of blue
check you know Twitter people with 5,000
followers just attacking yeah very
rarely about your ideas oh they'll just
make up something jordan peterson says
dogs are blue and cats are brown you
know and then somebody somebody
basically did that and i invited him on
the show to talk to you and then of
course he disappeared well I have it I
would say I have some problem with mood
regulation you know and so sometimes I'm
more irritable than I should be
sometimes I'm more I come across well no
I probably am more angry
then is optimal in the circumstance you
know I mean one of the rules of English
common law for example is that you're
more or less allowed to defend yourself
with minimum necessary force and I've
had you practice in practice in process
to use the minimum necessary for do you
really want to hit him right now that is
the temptation of you know anyway I
think we all struggle with that there
are certain times where somebody says
something is like oh I just oh I mean
it's there there's certain questions
that get asked and it's it's just a slow
pitch softball write down marry the
plate right it's like do I need to do I
need to hit this softball as hard as I
possibly have a sense of humor to break
okay
zing but it's it's really useful and I
have learned this it's really useful to
not defend yourself to vociferously
which is weird cuz you think well you
have the right to defend yourself like
no all no holds barred it's like no it
obviously doesn't work that way yeah you
have to defend yourself with minimal
necessary force and I think I managed
that in the channel 4 interview for
saint god yeah but I mean believe me
people have been talking to me about
that no one stopped for 15 months and
I'm listening and it wouldn't worked as
well if you hadn't done that
right if you just show laughter right if
you if you just gone right at her and
said what you are saying is so stupid
for these five reasons it would it would
have been bad I think I think actually
the fact that you sat there and he just
said no you're asking good questions and
you know the fact that you're asking
good questions demonstrates the
invalidity of your entire view boy that
was much more effective well right right
well not see see one of the things I've
been meditating on for the last years
there's a line in the New Testament says
resist not evil
think okay what okay what they are you
supposed to do why it's like because
it's really a difficult thing to figure
out do you really mean that you don't
resist evil well there's a couple of
problems is if you punch back then you
have a fight well but you can't just not
defend yourself like weakly you can't be
weak and not defend yourself but you can
be strong and defend yourself minimally
and that's a real art like that's that's
the essence of sophistication I would
say yeah and like I'm not you know I
come from kind of a rough place I've
come from northern Alberta I come from
the frontier you know and my town was
scraped out of the bloody Prairie 50
years before people moved before before
I lived there and so it's it's been and
it's been a continual challenge to
adjust my sophistication to the level of
challenge and I've I'm trying to do that
and do you think but I don't always
manage it yeah so to that point do you
think that we sometimes actually at a
deep level use identity politics against
ourselves in in this regard so you're
sitting across from Kathy she's female
yeah at some level do you think you may
be moderated it because of that because
had it been a male you know and you and
you talked about this often that we have
to act differently towards males and
females and there's a physical there's
physical reasons for that and biological
reasons for that but that had she been a
male say say the same exact age from you
from Alberta yeah all of that that
perhaps your response might have been a
little more forceful even even though
you're we're all agreeing your response
was done correctly
yeah and even-handedly yeah well I it's
hard to say but probably yes that's
interesting well because you did like I
can't I don't think that you can say
that you fight with a woman the same way
that you fight with a man that doesn't
mean you can't fight with a woman
doesn't mean you shouldn't but I don't
think the rules are the same now why are
the rules different well some of the
rules are there's a physical limit
that's much more stringent right I mean
there's a level of hinting at physical
threat that you can bring to bear in a
conversation between men that you cannot
bring to bear in a conversation with a
woman mm-hmm
so and the mech mechanics of that are
very very subtle and difficult and it's
especially challenging in an
intellectual discussion because an
intellectual discussion is a kind of war
and it isn't obvious how men and women
should go to war with one another we
don't know we don't know how to sort
that out you my sense has been on the
panels that I've done is that I
definitely have to pull my punches if
I'm on a panel with women that doesn't
mean that I don't it doesn't mean that
it's
less challenging intellectually but the
strategy and the attitude has to be
different it's much more likely that
you'll be seen as a bully if you bring
the same force to bear on a female
opponent as you would on a male opponent
yes so I wondered why CEO and Hillary
Clinton is a perfect example of this in
the political sphere where back in 2000
Hillary was running for Senate in New
York and Rick Lazio walk across the
stage and asked her to sign a piece of
paper and people like the mentor that he
basically assaulted her writing or if
Rick Lazich walked across stage to
another man and said sign this piece of
paper but like what a tough guy look at
that he's you're going to stand up to
him so I suspect in that case your
answer to this question is no you would
treat people saying if Piers Morgan that
night had been female you would have
done the exact same thing well I mean I
was I was actually relatively polite to
piers
so it's it's it to me it's I try to be
as polite as possible unless the person
is being very impolite in which case I'm
happy to go employed so I tried to
instead of trying to gauge sort of the
probably we're doing the same thing just
from different directions instead of
trying to you know determine how I
engage with the person by all of the
various you know well I let them take
the first punch basically you take the
first step in the waltz and then I'll
respond in kind so if you if you want to
if you want to act polite then I'm happy
to act polite with you and I'm happy to
have a nice cordial conversation if you
wanna get nasty then we'll get nasty and
we'll do that and I prep for interviews
so I'm happy if you want to go in the
mud I'm happy to go in the mud we can do
that yeah so I want to circle back to
something related to religion that we
that I wanted to get to earlier but
we're we're doing a lot here do you
think there's any difference or do you
both think there's any difference
Ben's belief in Ben's Jewish and your
belief is Christian comes from the
Christian tradition yeah does that
matter at all that whatever differences
there are in that little place where
you're both saying you know we see the
reasons why our morals and ethics and
all that come from this we're also
acknowledging you know the the real
world and biology and all of those
things whatever differences you may have
which I don't even know that we that any
of the three of us know what those
differences are
do they even matter they might all right
that would be a lie I'd love to figure
out if there are if there are I mean it
depends it for me it depends on the
brand of religion that a person is is
espousing so so let's just do this with
two I mean I mean so I'm a my feeling
and writing a book on this right
naturally so I there are certain
principles that obviously under the
Christianity that are from the Judaic
tradition yeah clearly manifestation of
the prophetic tradition yeah exactly I
mean it's it's essentially an attempt to
merge Jerusalem with Athens is is I
think the book of John is the most
obvious example using the logos as sort
of the unifying feature and writing the
whole thing in Greek right I mean that
was not the the the lingua franca of the
time those not what people were speaking
except in an educated circle so all the
Judaic principles things like a God
involved in history a God who cares
about individuals the notion that you
have a choice between good and evil so
choose good and that and so that you
will live long on the earth right the
all these things were taken forward into
Christianity the major distinctions in
terms of Christianity versus Judaism are
the idea that and again it depends on
your interpretation of Christianity
early Christianity sort of suggested
that history had ended with Christ and
then in later kind of iterations of
Christianity that was moved beyond right
it wasn't that history had ended it was
that Christ would come back when history
had reached its logical progression of
question of history didn't end but
original messianism was this is the
Messiah were done right histories over
that it was amillennialist religion
right depends on very few people think
that that's right so this is why I'm
trying to distinguish you know brands of
Christianity because obviously they're
serious differences even in basic root
level between Catholicism and Calvinism
and Lutheranism and all these things
have different iterations so you know my
very strong belief in free will in my
actual building of a moral system in
Judaism is building a moral system on
the notion of free will obviously runs
directly counter to for example
Calvinism my Calvinism suggests that
free will is is chimerical and there's
no basis for it and that God grants you
grace based on what he wants to do so it
depends on on the brand of Christianity
but I think that overall the conflict
between Christianity and Judaism in
large measure is especially in the early
conflict was political rather than
ideological and a lot of ways it was a
new religion attempting to establish its
own footing and was angry that the Jews
would not join this new religion and
tradition I think there are certain ways
in which Christianity you know like for
example the the main distinction between
Christianity Judaism that people usually
make is that Christianity is a great
space to religion in Judaism is in acts
based religion meaning the Judaism says
you sort of earn your way into heaven
right you earn your way toward a better
life and and Christianity says if you
believe right I'm the way the truth and
the life if you believe then you're good
but the truth is that Christianity sort
of back doors the the Judaic view by
saying if you really do believe then
you're going to act in these particular
ways that demonstrate your belief
there's this weird paradoxical
relationship between the idea of belief
in Christianity the belief that Christ
came to save everyone from their sins
and that all you have to do is admit
that and you're redeemed like there's
symbolic truth to that that would take a
long time to unpack but there's also an
injunction goes along with that to
imitate Christ in great life exactly so
it's like well I feel like a lot of
these distinctions are almost some of
them are almost a little false I mean
meaning that they're either Christian
mysteries of Judaism or Jewish mysteries
of Christianity and that when you get to
the root of it I mean this is what
Maimonides says that there are
significant differences between Judaism
Christianity but his view of
Christianity from a Jewish historical
point of view is that Judaism was never
bound to convert billions of people
around the world but Christianity was
specifically because we have a lot of
crap we got to do I mean Jews have we
have 613 commandments you know we got a
we have to keep kosher we have to do all
of these things I appreciate you doing a
lot of them for me yeah no problem
yeah I'll transfer over the by a
fertilized exactly but but I think that
Christianity ends up doing a lot of
those same things that you know there
was supposed to be stark distinctions
just under different guys so when it
comes to this is why in the modern world
when the discrimination between you know
from Christians toward Jews largely has
ended I think that what you're seeing is
this tremendous confluence between
particularly Orthodox Jews and observant
Christians my matters of on matters of
values because once Christianity in the
late 20th century in the mid 20th
century and in America more broadly with
Christianity because American Christian
he's very different than European
Christianity once once there was an idea
that Jews were not the enemy to be
converted but were
maybe you still want to convert me but
we're not gonna come at you with a knife
we're gonna come at you with a book
yeah and that we share a common
framework for how the world is supposed
to work you just may not agree with the
second half of the book right then I
think that that's that's created a
pretty good working relationship with
I'm sure this is why I'm struggling to
come up with what are the significant
differences and so I need I need a
Christian to tell me what is the signal
difference I can argue with my question
is I know my own religion better than I
know my question has been I don't know
if the role that the state plays in
Judaism and Christianity is the same
because I'm not sure what to make of the
like what I would say is the Jews put a
tremendous amount of emphasis on the
state as a mechanism for salvation
something like that that might be the
symbolic idea that underlies the
establishment of Israel and I would say
that in Christianity in the nation
remain like the government I mean the
nation right but then it gets tangled up
with the government right right so so so
right this is a distinction that
Christianity is univer Universal istic
religion or any idea is that it that in
the kingdom of God everyone is Christian
basically and Judaism is not in one
sense but it is another which is that
God identifies a nation that he
treasures as his own and he has a
special relationship with that nation
but Judaism is not exclusivist with
regard to who gets into heaven so
there's this there's this basic idea in
in Genesis that there are Commandments
that are given prior to the giving of
the Torah right that there's the well we
call the chef omits Hopa and off the
seven commandments that are given to the
sons of noah meaning all mankind and
these are things like no murder no
idolatry no adultery they basically
mirror a lot of the Ten Commandments and
so the idea in Judaism is that God it's
almost like a priestly caste God shows
the specific group of people to be a
light unto the nations by demonstrating
what a godly lifestyle looks like if you
dedicate every aspect of your life to
God and then he said everybody else I
know not everybody else is up to this
and I and in fact judy's are supposed to
try and turn away conference but if you
but you can still get into heaven the
idea that we are trying to force anyone
into into being Jewish that that's not a
thing so nationalism without you version
think about that psychologically as an
attempt to both manage the preservation
of group identity so that would be
culture a cultural identity which has
some utility and also to be able to
coexist with other
I think rhyming things in a different
way and again Judaism has had a long
history of just like every other
religion of sort of evolution on this
stuff right like when you're the bush of
joy the book of Joshua there's actual
forced conversion that happens in the
book of Joshua but by the time you get
to mid early Christianity and mid point
Judaism right because Judaism is lot
older and Christianity then you're
already talking about Jews who are not
looking to convert people they sort of
want to live in their own state they
don't want to bother anyone else for the
most part so the idea of like a tidal
wave of conquering Jews going out I mean
even to think about it now is hilarious
right nobody thinks about it that way
except if you're conspiratorial nutbag
what is it
but inquisitions usually work the other
way that's right so that's it so but so
with any anything that you might have
heard Ben just say would anything jibe
with a fundamental belief that you have
that would cause a problem you know to
me like Coleman I think the in society
well I think that one potential problem
that's that's worth discussing but it
would take forever to discuss it is the
relative role of the individual versus
the state I mean you see this argued out
in the prophetic books and in the Old
Testament I mean there's the Jewish
state and it's it's sort of the the
central player in some sense but there's
clear evidence that it can become
corrupt it can fall away and that a
prophet who's an individual has to step
forward and we revivify it right and so
there's tremendous emphasis on the
utility of the individual you see that
in judea judaism i would say overall
it's it's a it's a very cohesive it it
promotes in group cohesion let's say but
it also allows for individual expression
in a very interesting ways because
there's tremendous emphasis in jewish
culture on learning and an articulation
and mastery of ideas and so that
provides this space for the individual
to flourish with christianity you see
more of a move away i would say from the
idea of the state now that's not
necessarily without its troubles one of
the things young pointed out was well as
Christianity becomes more about the
individual the religion itself tends to
fragment like it did with Protestantism
until just fragments right to the point
where every individual is their own
church and then you have no continuity
and
tradition and the Catholics were kind of
a bulwark against that but I do think
that there's a discussion to be had
about the relative role of the
individual in redeeming the world let's
say versus the state in redeeming the
world and I would say the Christians
come down more strongly on the side of
the individual and the Jews come down
more strongly on the side of the state
well now like I'm willing to be
corrected about that but yeah I've never
actually been able to have a discussion
with anyone so I think there's some
truth to that I mean I think the idea of
you know in in Hebrew ami Sorrell liked
the idea of the nation of Israel being
paramount when you pray you pray in
collective terms you don't pray in
individual terms everything is is done
in terms of anachronisms we praying as a
group right supposed to pray in a minyan
so how do you swear that away in your
own ways how do you square that away yes
there's a lot there's a lot of play in
the joints meaning that so for example
to take the most to take the most
obvious example with you if you wanna
talk about the power of the Jewish state
I in in sort of biblical context there's
tremendous argument between whether a
kingship is a good thing or a kingship
is a bad Larry in the Old Testament
right and it says it says like Samuel
warns the Jewish people if you take a
king here's what's gonna happen it's all
gonna suck right and then they form a
kingship and things suck mhm and so
there's a strong case to be made that
kingship was not actually what was
wanted because you have an entire period
of just judges and the judges are
legitimately just individuals who are
trusted by the people but then they can
be supplanted at any time by another
judge who's not from a lineage so you
know that so when we say that that group
identity matters in Judaism it matters
to the extent that you're following
God's law but if you stray away from
that the idea I think Judaism has always
said that what you do is what makes you
part of the group not what you are so
Judaism has a weird dichotomy in it
that's largely driven by exigent
circumstances which is the idea of
biological Judaism versus the idea of
religious Judaism so I care very little
about biological Judaism like when
somebody says you know somebody is such
and such as Jewish no I'm Chomsky's
Jewish like so what I I really don't
care and and I think that most Orthodox
Jews
we basically biological Judaism or your
mom was Jewish
which is the way that it works in
Orthodox Judaism is the sort of the
entry ticket to being Jewish meaning you
have to either have converted in or your
mom has to be Jewish in order for you to
become fully Jewish but the practice is
what matters to me more than anything
else and that's where
get back into gray space versus acts
based a little bit right well it's also
that's another place where the the group
identity issue becomes paramount it's
like well there's this group well how is
membership defined well let's say it's
member it's defined by ethnicity
something that would be related to the
descent through the mother it's like
well that's a problem I'm not saying
it's wrong I'm saying it's a protein
markets a group say well this is a group
that only we can belong to us we're as
you can convert in this is why I say
when there's play in the joints hmm a
lot of the problems are solvable through
the idea that you can convert in so
Judaism says you can't convert out but
then we don't punish people to leave
right but is it right which is different
than Islam yes but it's actually a
relatively important but I mean and one
of the people who I work with it at my
company Andrew Klavan is a guy who's
born Jewish and now his Christian right
so my view he's Jewish but am I gonna
like drag him down to my synagogue like
that's not a thing right so it's is but
I think that what what the group
identity the good the one thing I will
say for group identity is that what we
have seen is that if there is lack of
group identity that group identity is
filled usually by nefarious groups
meaning that that people do have a
necessity
the idea of existing that you find your
meaning or you find your purpose or you
find your identity just in yourself as
an individual is not only wrong it's
belied by virtually all of human history
it's an argument for identity poet but
but what Judaism does what America does
it says find your identity in the ideas
yeah right that's the difference is when
I mean this is why I say I don't care
about biological Judaism you know
particularly that I care much more about
the ideas that you hold so I'm in favor
of group identity if group identity is
built around a set of ideas that are
worth preserving I'm not in favor of
group identity it like I am a
conservative that's a group identity
right but that's an identifier more than
it's an identity meaning it's it's a way
of identifying me as a person who thinks
this way and because I think there are
differences in modes of thought then
those group identities do matter I mean
this is why we get together this is why
we have discussions this is why we have
families yeah yeah but I'm glad you I'm
glad you said that the way you did
because I challenged myself on that all
the time because I talked about the
individual I believe in the
and I want to make sure that I'm not a
commonality if I if we can fit and this
is what I think is one of the things
that's broken down is we used to have a
common purpose like I have this
framework that I'm working on in the
book that I'm writing where I basically
say that in order for an individual to
be happy you need you need four things
you need individual purpose you need
individual capacity that the feeling
that you can accomplish that purpose or
at least make moves in that direction
you need a communal purpose you do need
to feel like you are part of a group
that's moving in the right direction and
you need communal capacity which both
allows the community to activate
together and also protects your rights
as an individual to do what you want to
do in pursuit of your individual purpose
and that's the apotheosis of happiness
and that's what I think the founding
fathers were trying to do in the United
States for example set up a framework
where you could fulfill all of these
things but you do need the idea of
communal purpose and one of the things
that's happened post enlightenment is
that people don't even think in terms
they either think purely in terms of
communal purpose or not at all in terms
of communal purpose they think either
purely in terms of communal purpose and
that's identity politics meaning I'm
black
therefore the black community should do
X right right or I'm Jewish therefore
the Jewish community should do X and
then there are people who think not in
terms of communal purpose at all meaning
full-on libertarian I make my own
meaning we don't have to have anything
in common
we and that's a lie even libertarians
believe we have to have an idea of
Liberty in common mhmmm live with other
people right exactly harmoniously and
when we don't and when we don't have any
of the when we don't have any sort of
communal purpose and we live with a
bunch of people with whom we share
nothing then it falls apart incredibly
quickly okay so so here's here's how the
Christian drama looks to me did it
addresses this issue right so Christ is
presented as a figure who's an absolute
master of his tradition right he's
debating with the Jewish elders when
he's 12 so think about it
psychologically is first year a child
and you're dependent on your parents and
then you have to make the move from
being a child dependent into the world
but you don't move from child to
individual you move from child to group
that's your teenage gang that's your
adolescence you have to catalyze your
group identity if you don't have a group
identity it's actually a developmental
failure right but then you might think
well wait a second group identity is
necessary but is it the highest is it it
doesn't
present the highest plane of moral
achievement the answer that is no you
have to emerge from your group as an
individual okay so now this is how I
read the Christian story symbolically
and this is a consequence mostly of
having students studied young he said
look you need group identity that's the
persona that you wear you have to have a
persona you have to be able to wear a
suit you have to be you have to simplify
yourself for other people you have to be
able to play the game otherwise your you
just have failed developmentally but if
you're only a persona then that's a big
problem partly because when the group
goes insane so do you uh-huh okay now
you gotta emerge out of the group okay
so now you need a symbol for what
emerges out of the group okay so Christ
is the symbol of what should emerge out
of the group speaking psychologically
bear the tragedy of life speak the truth
be willing to transform through death
that's the rules now I'm speaking purely
psychologically you learn something new
you learn it it makes you suffer the
part of you that's wrong has to die you
have to let go of that and it's hard
especially maybe you learn something
profound it's like it's like you have to
regrow an arm it's really painful you
know but you identify with the part of
yourself that transforms through
voluntary acceptance of suffering and
that's what Christ represents as a
symbol and I think that that's I think
that that's correct symbolically this is
what actually severed the relationship
between human Freud by the way because
Jung laid out his understanding of
Christianity in those terms and Freud
it wasn't the Jewish Christian thing you
know because Freud was really he he was
Jewish by ethnicity that's what no he's
not no not at all he just didn't want to
have anything to do with religious ideon
at all he thought that that would
introduce he called it like a tidal wave
of black tidal wave of occultism back
into what he regarded as a science he at
this point but I think you got the
symbolic structure right and so what
does that mean in relationship to
Christianity and Judaism well it's
really complicated because you have the
prophetic tradition in Judaism and the
prophets are also symbols of people who
emerge from the pathological group who
step forward
courageously and who reconstitute the
group yeah so you believe these people
could exist right now which which people
did the prophets
I think prophets of sorts exist always
yeah I think Dostoyevsky was a prophet
Nietzsche was clearly a prophet I mean
he predicted but it wasn't going to
happen in the toilet yeah can you
imagine predict well the reason i
asked-- it like that was because I think
when people when you say prophets I
think people think of like someone
coming down from heaven and their halo
on or some crazy but you think that
that's what I'm trying to get to the
reason I actually fully agree with this
in fact so does Maimonides I mean
Maimonides has an entire section and
guide for the perplexed about prophecy
and what he says is there's Moses level
prophecy which is the the legislating
prophet which is and he says he's the
only legislating prophet in the Jewish
view but all the other prophets are just
people who see things incredibly clearly
they're people who've studied philosophy
and who have studied human morality and
have studied the human being and then
that's way down on the iceberg that's
right it's the thing that makes them
different exactly and and so in that
sense people who predicting the the
thing about you know providing a certain
level of stability for folks and weren't
you know I think I think there are
levels of prophecy is what I'll say and
I think that the better you are at
recognizing human behavior and the
interplay of forces the better you are
at saying okay here's what's gonna
happen next week I think it's very
difficult for anybody to say here's was
gonna happen 100 years because if you
could predict that you'd make a lot in
the stock market but I think that you
can certainly you know as you well you
can also get a sense of plate tectonics
right like the details rub out but like
and I think that's where we're at now
like I believe we're in we are in a war
of ideas yeah we're were we're at a
point where we're debating the validity
of post-modernism now and that's tainted
with neo Marxism and that should have
been laid to rest a hundred years ago
but what they were just I mean the
reason that that Moe post modernists
can't let go of Neel Marxism is because
there's no impetus forward in
post-modernism that's that's its
fundamental flaw it's like well there's
no grand narrative it's okay like what
are you gonna do tomorrow well I don't
know because everything's the same as
everything else it's like well you can't
live you cannot live that way it's
impossible to live that way well we'll
just sneak some Marxism in the back door
it's like well that's that's prima facie
evidence in my estimation that your
philosophy is pragmatically lacking even
though you can make a perfectly coherent
case for it it's like you can't live it
out you just can't do it so you have to
sneak in this pathological Marxism in
the back door
well no that just invalidates your
entire system but apart from all that I
think the postmodern objection to
meaning is actually wrong while we
talked about this earlier I do believe
that there's a transcendent ethic and I
do believe that it touches on the
metaphysical I believe it people
experience that because people are
perfectly capable of having unutterably
profound religious experiences and the
naturalistic materialists don't know
what the hell to do with that they have
no idea what to do with that fact say
well it's delusional it's like well hang
on a sec people who have those
experiences appear to be more successful
and healthier who's like so and exactly
in what manner is that delusional and if
you induce it in the lab with psilocybin
for example among people who are dying
of cancer their fear of death goes away
it's like that's you're gonna just lay a
delay that out there as delusional Oreo
that quit smoking 85% success rate with
one mystical experience on psilocybin
but this is 85% cessation rate and
smoking yes completely
and with MDMA ecstasy the three
treatments with MDMA that's what the
current research indicates produces a 72
percent cure rate for intractable
post-traumatic stress disorder it's like
those are miracle cures and no one and
they have to be accompanied by the
mystical experience no one knows how to
account for that and so so it's a very
physical thing I mean in a case like
that you talk about ayahuasca or any of
these things right the you're eating
something you're ingesting something
smoking it whatever it is
it's physical it's here and now but the
experience is metaphysics is meta Fisher
that's a place where the biological and
the transcendent touch and we don't know
what to make of that yeah well that's
why psychedelics through our whole
culture into such a such a flip this
upside down no one ever knew what to do
with them you know I mean the Indians
regarded psilocybin as food of the gods
for a reason and when when people have
encountered psychedelic substances
throughout human history that's always
how they've been characterized that's
right food of the gods
it's like
we're of them but there they opened the
door to the transcendent and well I
think the evidence that they are doing
something that psychedelic substances
are doing something that we seriously
don't understand at all not a bit is
overwhelming Rick Strassman wrote a book
on his experiences giving DMT to a whole
bunch of people down in he was at in
Austin I think and Strassman is a pretty
straight scientist you know he was
interested in measuring psycho
physiological responses to the drugs
well he'd give people DMT and they all
came back with the same story I was
blasted out of my consciousness I went I
met a whole bunch of alien beings they
were really surprised I was there and
then I came back and it was the most
real thing that's ever happened to me
and Strassman would say well you know
well you had a Jungian archetypal
experience or it was a dream and they'd
say you don't you can't understand
yeah he got so distraught because of
these continual reports that he had to
stop doing the research yeah like I'm
not making a claim for anything
metaphysical here but I'm definitely
pointing out that there are undeniable
realms of human experience that involve
religious experience and a sense of the
infinite transcendent that looked like
they're healthy and that you cannot deny
yeah well so what are you supposed to do
with that you well you say barks and you
say well we're not going to pay
attention to it's like that's not gonna
work yeah that's not gonna work and I've
done a lot of those things that you just
mentioned and virtually always had good
experiences on them now as someone that
I'm pretty sure has never smoked weed no
mushrooms you have ever done MDMA take a
drink yeah I mean I've done all of those
things I don't really do well I mean I
smoked some weed but I don't I'm not
doing haven't done ecstasy in years and
mushrooms I did do about a year ago and
I had a great day and I kind of wandered
around and I thought you know I felt
some some things happening I didn't when
I did them in college I had a couple of
those type of transcendent feeling I was
just part of something whatever but so
when you hear all this as someone that
doesn't partake in any of this stuff
what do you make of of that that people
can perhaps use some substances that
you're not down
on a personal level to get to a place
that I think you actually think is a
good place yeah I mean I think the
answer is that it depends on you know
the level of expertise the person using
it is could suggest you know the idea
like I'm not against prescription
medication so if you're talking about
you know an actual program that's gonna
better somebody's life that's one thing
but if it's somebody who's just I want
to have a religious experience let me
pop some LLC right then there's some
serious downsides to drugs that I I do
wonder if it is necessary well two
things one the in in in Judaism and I
keep reverting back to this because I
know it's the religion I know but there
there's two kind of schools of thought
with regard to Judaism one are called
the the the mr. Ogden these are people
who are sort of enlightenment mentality
hard science folks in their custom now
consider murder the people who see for
the Chabad they have the the big beard
and have to pay us and they and they
like to dance and they drink on on Purim
and all this and then they're wonderful
people they they do great outreach
specifically because they're so
spiritual and I tend to be more of a
snagit than a facet meaning that it's I
try to make you dance oh it's nice not
pretty but I I try to get to
spirituality through reason as opposed
to through experience mm-hmm simply
because I think that well I know people
who have had religious experience and
its really changed them I think they're
also a lot of people have a religious
experience in a last for a given amount
of time and then they're done with the
religious experience and they just go
back to doing whatever they're doing
where I mean this is what you were doing
in college so I think that if you're
looking for that as a gateway out of
whatever it is that is troubling you in
terms of a lack of purpose like a
permanent solution maybe that works for
a small number of people but I highly
doubt that most people can find a level
of purpose necessary to drive the
entirety of the rest of their lives
outside of a framework of conscious will
moving them in the direction of doing
the right thing
Young told people he talked about
mescaline and LSD in the context of
Huxley's introduction of those
substances into the Western world and he
said two things in his inimitably wise
manner the first thing he said is beware
of unearned wisdom yeah man that's great
and he also said you you have to be very
careful about about entering the realm
of the Gods because you end up with a
responsibility that might be more
crushing than you can tolerate and it's
the same kind of idea and I thought I've
never read any one who wrote wiser words
about the dangers of psychedelic use
than that because he didn't say well
none of this is real
he said it's more real than you want it
to be and so watch the hell out and I
think that's extremely good advice and
it is very difficult for people to
integrate those experiences into their
life although my experience with people
has been and I've seen this with lots of
people they've said that they've done
mushrooms for example how to mystical
experience and that that provided them
with a moral compass that they lacked
before that never went away and I've
talked to many people who've had that
experience so but you know I've also
been in Amsterdam watching the 50 year
old punk rockers trip out on mushrooms
and beer and go pound out some street
kid you know there's the downside of
transcendence is something that's not to
be trifled with and there's also the
opportunity not to go to heaven but to
go to hell and that does happen to
people and that can be that can induce
post-traumatic stress disorder
essentially so you know beware of beware
of wandering in realms that it's not
competent to wander in there yeah that
that's my that's my central take it and
I think it's very good for you like I
think that what you're doing really
works because you know you you do kind
of what I did with the biblical lectures
except you take it to a even greater
extreme I would say you're so rational
in your approach like people know that
you have a religious overview let's say
but you don't use that you use it less
than I do I would say yeah and I think
it really works well for you I think
it's very affirming I think it's hard to
force faith on people and I think it's
wrong to force faith on people so I'm
also counterproductive exactly exactly
and I I'm not preaching that you have to
agree with how I got to these values to
say that these values are necessary for
the civilization and this is essentially
what I've said to Sam when I was
debating him is you know he said well
you know a lot of religious people he
sort of suggested that I you know think
that atheists can't be moral people and
I said I don't think that that's true at
all I mean the point that I'm making is
you have to get to these values to have
a civilization how you get to those
values in my view you know I think
requires a leap of faith you can make
that leap of faith a variety of
different ways but you're going to end
up needing these central values at root
if you're gonna build a civilization off
of that so whether you do that through
you know the kind of method
the team wants to get to what was weird
is that you know Sam and I come from
completely different perspectives on
virtually everything but we share
probably 90 to 95 percent of our values
yeah that's what I would suggest is that
those values are rooted in a
judeo-christian civilization that is
mixed with a Greek civilization that
brought us to the same place because we
broke five miles from each other so of
course we have the same values right
yeah here's counter-arguments that
basically would be that you're really
talking about enlightenment values but
you would say those values ultimately
came about that is that's actually a
silly argument that those are
enlightenment well I hope you guys have
already made short shrift of that it's
like Sam can't be an evolutionary
biologist and say that the values that
run Western civilization sprang from the
Enlightenment it's like you don't get to
have those two time frames at the same
time I may have slightly snorting words
it's either I disagree with you a little
bit about the atheist issue because I
think this is the reason it's like if
you think about the layers of the mind
like the iceberg analogy it's like well
you've got your your your your patterns
of action and then you've got your
justification for those patterns of
action you might think that those are
rational but but then there's something
underneath that which is like the images
that represent reality and the stories
that represent reality and then there's
something underneath that even and I
think that to be religious is to have
all of those things in order
simultaneously and I don't think that
you could have an ethic that's only
grounded in rationality because I think
the integrity of that rationality
depends on agility of stories that you
don't understand that exists so Liz so
let me rephrase do I actually agree with
everything you just said when I say that
we have to agree on these values in
order for us to build a civilization how
you get there is your own business I
mean on an individual level I don't mean
that every way you get to those values
is equally valid I think that the
otherwise it salmon I would agree right
right I do not think that the mode of
thinking from evolutionary biology to
the values that I think are necessary
for building a civilization are even see
I see weaknesses coming up in Sam's
representations for this reasons the
first thing is he has to dispense with
consciousness and he has to dispense
with freewill
and I actually think that's deeply
problematic and I think the reason he
has to do that and Dennett does it do is
because there is something
metaphysically strange about
consciousness and you can't allow for
that if you're
this materialist and so I'm more than
willing to say look I I don't understand
consciousness at all and the more I
think about it the less I understand it
because it seems to be the linchpin of
being without consciousness there's no
being right I'd say well the material
reality continues it's like well maybe
and maybe not because we do not
understand the relationship between time
and space and consciousness so there's
no it's not self-evident that what
you're saying is true it might be true
but even if it was true well exactly how
does the universe that has no
consciousness in it exists like how do
you parameterize it does it have a
duration does it have a size does it
have any qualities like what is love
it's like a video game that no one's
playing right it's like well what is
that exact well that this is this is
where we get to you know back to that
three-hour conversation that you and Sam
had as to the nature of truth and what
exactly truth is and one of the things
that I always I don't want to you know
critique Sam's ideology without him here
to defend himself although I mean here
it actually actually do that it'd be a
lot of fun but one of the things that
I've always found weird is that he and I
have precisely the same notion of an
objective truth but I don't understand
where he's getting his from meaning that
like I'm getting I don't either like
whoa and he also because if you if you
if you base your viewpoint on in a
materialist evolutionary biology than
what you would success is what you'd say
is the truth is that which is most
biologically successful right that
that's the claim I was making when I
talked to Sam right exactly which is
which is your claim and also a claim
that leads to religion because
biologically speaking religious
believers are more biologically
successful than non religious believers
religion religious belief evolved right
that's the thing normally did religious
belief evolve clearly it evolved it's
one of the human universals the capacity
for religious experience evolved what
you might say why well maybe you could
you could take the viewpoint that seems
to be characteristic of Steven Pinker
and say well it's a spandrel it's just a
side effect of something more
substantial and my objection to that is
define your spandrels first right you
know you know you don't get to eat right
you don't get to define a way the side
effects of the drug right yeah when did
you know when people talk about drugs
very often what they'll do is they'll
say well you know the drug is for a
headache but it has the side effect
causing you cancer right I go no the
drug causes cancer yeah maybe the
headache is the side effect I mean every
one of those prescription commercials
you know a headache diarrhea and nausea
thoughts of suicide etc etc but York off
Michael you know it's really nice
alright here's our do so I want to be
very respectful of both the year times
but yours particularly because you're
doing like a two-hour lecture tonight at
the Orpheum there might be a surprise
guest there I don't want to say who so
we're gonna do a half hour more if you
guys can do that we're going to do Q&A
from from the audience but I do want to
ask you guys one other thing first and I
just want to try to get this to truly be
as as personal as I can get out of you
guys in front of thousands and thousands
of people as these last couple years had
happened and as you both risen in
profile and you're out there saying what
you think all the time in defending your
beliefs and and being friends with
people like Sam who you disagree with on
different things and all that what what
sort of been the most personal thing
that you've kind of struggled with along
the way I want to go deep before we open
it up to the audience well for me it's
two things one is for it's not so bad
now it's still pretty bad like I've
lived in constant existential terror of
saying something that will be fatal
because I've been in the situation for
15 months where well and there's been a
few things that I've done or said that
have people have argued skirted the
edges and perhaps they did because if
you say 10,000 things something's going
to skirt the edge but I've been I've had
to watch myself in an intensely
hyper-vigilant manner to ensure that I
don't provide those who would like to
provide those who regard me as their
enemy with the tools to dispense with me
yeah and you know I have my family
resting on me as well as well as
whatever else I happen to be doing so
that's been extraordinarily intense and
the other thing is is persistent feeling
of surreal su reality that see one of
the one of the markers of post-traumatic
stress disorder is that you can't
believe that what's happening to you is
real
it's like I felt that literally I felt
that way every single day since
September of 2016 and so I just cannot
get accustomed to well even just to this
handles that I've been involved in it's
just one scandal after another
yep you know and I I I don't know I
don't have a frame of reference within
which to put this yeah I think that I'll
just briefly say for myself I think I
mean both of those right we're all
afraid of the one thing that you
accidentally just miss speak or say some
thank you right out of context a wave of
so exactly so say something stupid
defending yourself you know which you
could certainly do or even I mean I've
been writing column since I was 17
right no there's one line with you that
you wants one tweet that you sent that
you regret now and it's like I don't
regret the tweet in the actual tweet
thread I explained exactly what I meant
in the tweet but nobody ever reads the
next tweet it literally explains what I
meant in that tweet yeah we don't have
to mention which tweet to just add more
field but very quickly cuz I do want to
get to the to the audience questions I
think for me the second one is the one
that I struggle with the the surreal one
that sometimes I'll look and see what
people are saying about Dave Rubin this
and then I for a moment I'm like wait a
minute I'm Dave even if it's something
they're nice like wait a minute that
that's me and and also just the other
part of you know we sort of live close
to each other you know proximity and
I'll go out and you know the woman at
Petco will say something nice to me and
then for some reason they always say
they like been more but they look great
but like I go out and then I'm like wow
like the things that I'm doing have
meaning to people like that there's a
lot of built-in pressure or at least for
me there's a lot of cycle responsibility
yeah you know and while I feel that too
because now when whenever I go somewhere
people come up and they they almost
always say the same thing they say you
know I was in a pretty dark place and
I've been listening to your lectures and
they've really helped thanks a lot and I
think man if you could have your wish
and you could what strangers you can say
to you on the street what a cool thing
no kidding but it's also kind of a
terrifying thing because you know people
have pinned well let's say they've
pinned their hopes on what I what I'm
saying that's the right way to say it
but in some sense that also means they
pinned their hopes on me and like I'm
not by any stretch of the imagination
perfect like far from it and so I do
live in constant terror of sinking my
ship in in a you know in a particularly
awful manner
I still like that's the most likely Oh
turn away in this or you just wake up in
terror
in the middle of the night that somebody
is going to take something that you said
out of context and you think did I
really say it exactly the way I meant to
say yes right that's I mean that that
yeah that's that's a definite thing and
then you and the upside is that people
listen to what we're saying and take it
seriously and the downside is that what
we're taking and taking it seriously
yeah so for you then would it be
something I mean without getting to in
the weeds like saying related to like
security or something I mean you when
you travel now you have to have someone
with you I mean that file under surreal
because I actually have never thought of
myself as in serious physical danger
even when people say you're serious
physical danger I think that's all like
this is America am I really in pesco
like whenever I do these lectures and
I've got a security team of ten people
around me when I tell myself maybe it's
me whistling past the graveyard is I'm
the safest guy in the room I'm more
discerning today but but it's yeah I
mean that's weird
the the confluence of politics now is so
odd I mean the last night during the
State of the Union they introduced Trump
is the president the United States and I
just find myself laughing out loud
because what in the world is going like
I forget that I like a lot of the stuff
he's doing like what in the world and
and there's a I was reading a book about
Brahmans the other day and in this book
about Brahms it talks about how he's
hobnobbing with with various other
composers has good friends with Dvorak
and he has fights with vogner and he's
and he's and he's walking in these
circles and I thought wow that must have
been a cool thing to walk in these
circles and then I look around I
realized that the people with I work
within a hundred years this may be the
people that they're writing about right
is like and that was the day that
Shapiro got together with Rubin in
Jordan and talked about deep issues of
philosophy and you realized well how did
we end up in this position like oh this
is one of the issues of existential
terror I have is are we the best that we
have to offer for example I know like
half the people in the White House and I
think is this the pinnacle like our like
and that's not a rip on the people in
the White House that's a rip on humanity
yeah like is this the best that we can
do for you know so like why should I be
in this position of prominence like
there have got to be people smarter than
I am I mean a lot of them there's a
beautiful thing yeah yeah I would hope
my god I mean if you ask somebody this
is this thought experiment the other day
which would which would you prefer to be
the smartest man in the dumb
civilization or the dumbest man in a
smart civilization and I think I can
honestly say I prefer to be the dumbest
man in a smart
and some sort of something disquieting
about being seen anyway as one of the
smart people in a dumb civilization well
you know what there are literally
thousands of people watching this live
obviously and that'll watch this over
the next couple months and hopefully
there will be some people that will come
up with some better ideas than Ben
Shapiro and Jordan and Gabe Rubin and
we'll go find sign ups do
all right here's all ready we're gonna
take a quick little break I know already
they're giving me the signal we have
like roughly 400 billion questions we
will do our best to be brief that's
that's easy for you guys right all right
so give us just like a minute or two
hang tight right there questions in a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we're gonna try to plow
through as many questions as possible as
I said Jordan is at the Orpheum Theatre
here in downtown Los Angeles tonight I'm
it sold out already right so there's
gonna be riots outside but if you have a
ticket you will see Jordan later here we
go alright super chat for Jordan we're
gonna try to do these as quickly as
possible I've recently taken your
understand myself personality test and
scored very low in all aspects of
agreeableness I have the cognitive
ability to emulate these aspects and do
so for the benefit of my kids and
community is emulation enough or do I
have to actually take the steps in
showing and honestly showing
agreeableness can you fake it basically
well if if if emulation is motivated by
let's call it a noble aim the
understanding that reciprocity is
necessary there is evidence showing that
disagreeable people do quite a bit
better if they go out of their way to do
things for other people do they make
that a practice and the thing is is if
if you're an introvert you have to
become a conscious extrovert right if
you're if you're so in if you're
disagreeable you have to become
consciously agreeable you can do it and
emulation is the first step to
incorporating it I would say so if
you're doing it to manipulate people
well that's a different story right man
I mean there's there's a ton of people
here that donated on super chat just to
say hi and thank you so hello to
everybody this quick one for Ben I think
we've already hit this but any chance of
a future discussion with Milo no ok fair
enough yeah how people have something to
say ok here's an interesting one and
Jordan during the break mention that we
should be doing a show on the future at
some point do you think like me that
abortion and artificial intelligence
will eliminate humanity as we know it
I'm watching this new philip k dick
thing on hulu now so I'm very very come
on you can do it you're a sci-fi guy you
guess what we could talk about AI am
yeah
AI is going to transform what human
beings are dramatically we're going to
have to decide in what manner we want to
be transformed and we should bloody well
hope and pray that the people who are
leading the technological revolution are
careful and ethical people but it hasn't
that ship sailed I mean I feel like we
know already that that's not how it's
going to be we know there's so many
problems related to the diversity memo
and the algorithms and all that already
from the tech company that's nice
people working on these you should be
you should be terrified of this
transhumanism it's like what do we want
to turn into we need a vision of the
future which is why we need to talk
about the future yeah whatever I think
one of the things we need to do
collectively is to develop it's like
okay
I believe that the human race can do
anything it wants in the next 30 years
you know Gates was talking Bill Gates
was talking the other day about
eradicating malaria he's really set on
eradicating the five major transmissible
diseases that could happen yeah it's
like we could eliminate most of our
problems it's like well we should
concentrate on the future that we would
like to have and try to bring it into
being and then maybe we can get
artificial intelligence to serve that
instead of serving whatever inchoate
and pathological set of principles that
it's serving now which we will suffer
for yeah well let's cross our fingers
what is the likelihood that the SJW
postmodern left collapse will happen
soon basically um I think that it's more
likely than people think it is I'll put
it that way I think that right now the
sjw's think that they're on top and they
think that they are ascendant and I
think the growing popularity of people
who are not that especially among young
people I mean my entire audience is
young people legitimately my entire
audience is people who are under the age
of 40 and probably half my own it's
under the age of 25 and I would probably
imagine it's the same for you Jordan you
know I think that the there's a whole
group of young people who are just
looking at this stuff and innately
saying I'm bored with it there's nothing
here and so I think there's a good shot
that the identity politics is actually
an older person's game yeah all right
you know we're only going to do two more
what cat ago categorize all of these and
maybe the next time you guys are on hits
we'll hit some of these but we'll do two
more because I think they're good they
sort of hit right where we're going here
you both can answer this but it's
directed to you Jordan any follow-up on
your call earlier this month for
students to stand up and leave the
classroom whenever the teacher mentions
equity diversity and justice and I know
this is something you've talked about a
bit about how you deal with a college
professor junior high and high school
guests to talk to their parents about
well I was trying to provide people with
easy markers to note that their children
are being indoctrinated and not educated
I said well if they're talked about
equity diversity inclusivity white
privilege or gender it's time to leave
the Klaus and I now that didn't cause
nearly as much trouble that video as I
thought it might yeah I mean that's a
pretty dangerous idea to be telling that
to a 13-14 yes yes but it's also
dangerous not to tell them that and I
mean it's particularly germane in
Ontario where the Elementary Teachers
Federation of Ontario has explicitly
developed a social justice curriculum
with that name whose explicit purpose is
to transform kids from kindergarten to
grade eight into social justice
activists they've even bent the
selection of literature to promote that
so they're perverting art for ideologies
and that's the official policy the
Elementary Teachers Federation of
Ontario if they're gonna do that play
that game then for me to say look here's
five phrases that that are pretty
decently diagnostic you can be pretty
certain that if these topics come up in
your class that you're now into
indoctrination territory yeah I think
people should walk what's the risk
though of saying that to a kid that may
come home and the parents may not even
understand these issues enough to defend
risk risk everywhere man it's it's it's
the risk of going along with it there's
a risk of standing up against it and I
believe and that's why I've been doing
what I've been doing is that I believe
that the risk of stating that this is
dangerous and should stop is way less
than the risk of going along with it I'm
with ya all right so this is gonna be
this can be the last one for now we will
pick this up another point and we also
discussed during the break that maybe we
can do some kind of live thing together
with this whole crew of people that
we're talking about we'll see who we can
get to do that probably in LA but we'll
see this one I'm sure I've asked you
some form of this in our other
interviews before but I think it's it's
the one that sort of hands this back to
the audience for both of you for some
time now I've wanted to start doing
something to protect liberty and Western
values etc but I have no idea where to
start what's the most useful thing I can
do to start as an average person I mean
I think they might answer this is sort
of the same answers to what you should
just do in life generally find something
that you're good at find something you
like to do and find something that's
useful and where are those three things
can conflate well were those three
things overlap that's where you're gonna
be the happiest and that's where you're
gonna feel you're making a difference
because if you only have two of those
three things then you're butting your
head against a brick wall if you'd like
to do something and you think that it's
gonna influence other people but you
suck at it it's not gonna work for you
so try to openly identify your own
skillset find what it is that you're
good at
and then figure how do I use this
skillset something I'm good at and enjoy
doing how do I use that for a purpose
that is that is useful and it sounds
like this you already have your purpose
it's just a question of what can you do
that that actually helps effectuate that
purpose so without knowing your skillset
I don't know but if I knew your skillset
then I could help define what you could
do with that to get from point A to
point B yeah so I suspect you probably
yeah but what about the courage but I
would just add a little bit to that it's
like there are some things that you'll
see that will bother you some of those
are your problems that's why they bother
you like there's lots of things in the
world that are happening that don't
bother you it's like they're not your
problems things that bother you for some
reason are your problems find something
that bothers you that you could fix that
you could start fixing and start fixing
it that's that's it and and you know you
should do it confidently doing a domain
where you're competent in a domain where
you're interested but there are things
that you'll see around you that you
think could be set right that you could
set right it's like go for it you'll get
good at it and then you'll set bigger
and bigger things right that's nuts
that's where to start start small you
won't end small I mean I can tell you in
the most intimate way as you guys are
now in my house in my studio that we
built that's funded by the people that
are watching this I just had an idea and
I started talking about it I started a
YouTube channel that literally everyone
watching this can do you start I mean
look at the three of us we all started
putting stuff out there going is this
gonna work none of us were greenlit I've
never been greenlit or had any respect
from the industry all together listen
guys it was a pleasure we're about you
what do you do before show you can take
a nap maybe I'm definitely going to take
a nap yeah you don't take naps
you take naps yeah I have two kids one
just turned 4 yes it's been a pleasure
guys let out some ways to expand this to
the wider group you have some live
events and everything else and we'll
keep this conversation going thank you
guys for all the comments I promise you
we're gonna we're gonna list everything
out so whether you submit it on super
chat or patreon we'll try to get back to
all this stuff and when I do my live
streams I'll try to address some of this
directly so thanks for watching and
thank you for YouTube for actually
allowing the stream to be up what are
the chances were monetized by tomorrow
oh god I'd hate to bet luckily I haven't
been demonetised I don't have any
well let me self-select that all right
all right great thanks everybody nice
you